back with family but broken inside this
is Samia David she was trafficked to
China and married off to a stranger
after just two months she returned to
Pakistan deathly ill malnourished very
very very low weight according to the
height and weight criteria she was very
lean so slim a month later she was dead
samia's story is not unique and is part
of a disturbing wider trend in human
trafficking Chinese men seeking Brides
are fueling an illegal but lucrative
cross-border practice it targets girls
and women often from Pakistan's
impoverished Christian minority lured by
the promise of a better life and money
for their parents they're told they're
going to marry wealthy Chinese
Christians more often than not they end
up in some of China's poorest and
conservative areas where its one-child
policy has led to too many men and not
enough women once across the border
young brides are at the mercy of their
new husbands and every name in one room
- fighting to start from the in
pregnancy yeah there are a lot of
spiders because my room behind my room
is mud I told him these spiders are here
I feel eating I'm not feeling relaxed
and he's not listening you say no you're
you don't know you're crazy and he other
women have described coercive behavior
physical abuse and even forced
prostitution whatever the Chinese grooms
want to do with them they can no one is
there to see what happens to the girl
it's the height of cruelty
but also a profitable business that's
practiced openly in China although
Beijing says it has zero tolerance for
any illegal cross-border marriage
behavior a pakistani investigation into
the trafficking networks led to a number
of arrests last year but efforts to
bring the traffickers to justice have
stalled investigators say they've come
under pressure from government officials
to curtail their work for fear of
damaging Pakistan's increasingly close
economic ties to Beijing and as long as
Pakistan turns a blind eye the lucrative
and distressing trade of Brides to China
will continue joining me now for more on
this story is Osman irani she's the
co-chair of the Human Rights Commission
of a Pakistan mr. irani welcome
why are government officials so hesitant
to crack down on bride trafficking into
China
unfortunately when ever since these
cases have been reported
the government's response has been like
luster and what people are saying is I
mean pitches as you know the China is a
very like economic ally of Pakistan and
they are providing is a lot of aid in
the form of this the cp+ military aid so
all these factors I think are coming
into the picture
where these cases are not being
addressed as force trafficking and the
government is not responding in trying
to recover many of these girls and
family isn't reaching out for help
so that looks like a grim prognosis does
that mean that these cases we will see
more of in the future so far till April
20 19 through the travel documents when
when initial investigation took place
629 cases were reported documented and I
even till today we the numbers must have
gone up because no action has been taken
so obviously if the
government is going to look the other
way the traffickers will continue with
what they are doing
there's a lot of people are making money
the local authorities in the sense the
local community gets involved in these
trafficking cases because they are
benefiting so we the madrasas the some
of the churches in small areas so it's
also Christian population that is being
targeted and some Muslim communities
know why exactly these poor communities
or these minority communities I guess
the minority is being the poorest and
obviously for poverty is one of the
reasons that parents agreed to sell
their daughters like annuity they're
told that were created newly like these
are Muslim Chinese what it was la mean
the people mostly Brides feel that okay
we are we are doing a good deed
by marrying our daughter who you know
converted Muslim in most cases obviously
this is not the case issue is birch
cultural we all know the factors behind
this marrying or trafficking of young
girls and is not only Pakistan it's
spreading to other countries also right
that's why we leave it but thank you so
much for joining us osman irani